you are watching ColdFusion TV
so just the other day there was a video
posted about a new type of battery that
can actually charge a phone in 30
seconds so I know you're thinking are
this kind of sounds a bit familiar I've
heard this before but this time there is
an actual video of the real-life
prototype so I already posted this on my
Google+ page but for the benefit of
everyone I decided to make a quick video
on this let's check out what's going on
so far on this channel were featured two
very different approaches to making your
battery last longer the first the super
capacitor approach the state-of-the-art
was advanced by an 18-year old school
student and the second approach just
better efficiency and this was done by
an Prius out of these two solutions only
AM Prius has made it to the level where
no other company before them has and by
this I mean production and financial
backing from a smartphone manufacturer
if you want you can click on the screen
right now to find out more there are
countless other fringe cutting edge
technologies such as graphene and
solid-state silicon storage that just
haven't made it out yet but now AM Prius
isn't the only company that's gotten
this far there's now a new contender who
has financial backing from a smartphone
manufacturer and they have this
demonstration that we're about to see
the latest company to enter the race
this time around is store doc and I mean
race in a literal sense it literally has
become a race now a race to solve the
final hurdle in our newly mobile lives
the more we go mobile the more prize
money there is sitting at the end of the
finishing line store dot have a new type
of organic battery that was actually
developed from the most unlikely of
sources it came from the search for a
cure for Alzheimer's disease CNN had an
interview with CEO Doron Meyers Dorf and
they have more on the story the Israeli
company behind the video and its founder
and CEO Doron Meyers daf tells me the
technology was born out of research
being conducted in the search for a cure
for Alzheimer's at Tel Aviv University
and during that research these specific
amino acids will isolated and we managed
to use those amino acids and peptides
and create nano crystals we call them
nano doll
these nano crystals have these special
properties that enable us to use them in
in various devices such as a battery
store docks nano dots are used in both
the electrode and the electrolyte and
according to store dot the electrical
properties of these Nano dots allow the
electrode to charge much more rapidly
while still discharging at a similar
rate to lithium-ion batteries and the
best part is that it's cheap it's made
from naturally occurring organic
compounds okay so let's see what this is
all about let's see this in action I'm
going to play it in real time mind you
that thing on the back of that galaxy s3
is the battery so it's just a matter of
plugging it in and away we go
so as you can see it's pretty cool it
does work but of course we're not
completely home free yet there's still a
couple of snags as you can see the size
of the battery needs to go down a lot
the aim is within the next year or so to
get the battery small enough to fit into
your average smart
and we're fully charged that was
actually pretty quick the race for a
better battery is now officially on
there are now two companies to my
knowledge that have financial backing
from a major smartphone manufacturer
with a serious shot at a mass-produced
better battery alright so that's the
latest news thanks for watching guys if
you enjoyed that don't forget to give a
thumbs up share your thoughts below and
pass it on to a friend if you found it
interesting and there is a special
announcement coming up the one click
install app for the Vox US launcher is
an alpha right now and testers will be
needed next week more news on that soon
cold fusion
it's me thinking